la fin d'année arrivent en tout le monde
recherche les bons prix les meilleures
affaires pour faire des cadeaux pour en
acheter pour tout le monde pour que ça
sympa tout si tout ça est justement il
ya une fête qui va depuis quelques
années vous le savez ça vous aura pas
échappé aux faux pas une fête [ __ ] en
événements je dirais ça l'a fait c'est
plutôt noël c'est plutôt après
l'événement c'est le black friday et le
cyber monday pour avoir les meilleures
offres les meilleurs prix je vous dis
que ce soit pour vous pour vous équiper
ou alors pour préparer les cadeaux pour
noël comme ça vous les achetez beaucoup
moins cher et ça c'est malin alors je
délirais de pour noël si vous êtes des
enfants c'est le père noël voilà c'est
de père noël sont pas les paroles c'est
le père noël faire des conneries c'est
ce pack pour tous leurs atouts pas cette
vidéo
[Musique]
j'ai noté plusieurs d'autres qui sont
vraiment très intéressante je vous mets
tous les liens en bas dans la
description alors j'ai sélectionné des
produits que je connais des productions
y en a plein d'autres qui sont vraiment
intéressantes si vous parlez de produits
un parent j'ai sélectionné que je trouve
vraiment vraiment intéressants qui sont
des offres qui sont vraiment cool par
rapport au tarif on peut trouver
actuellement sur le marché
et puis il y aussi pas mal d'offres un
peu général un peu global je me tous les
liens en bas de la description aller
jeter un petit coup d'oeil vous verrez
sur qui sont vraiment très très
intéressante on va commencer par les
offres hypra cool
du côté des chiens au oui alors j'ai
tout noter là je n'ai pas appris par
coeur parce que les tarifs jour d'outré
c'est un petit peu un but d'hab il ya un
truc qui lâche moins intéressant pour la
mobilité demi et scooters la trottinette
avec des chiens au mythe que j'étais
juste là à côté mais vous le voyez pas
et j'étais à côté de la moto comme des
moyens allez allez allez on regarde on
regarde aller là l'appel et la vrille et
la haye et là vous avez la complète vous
avez le vélo de mon fils vous avez la
trottinette laval guy hoquet là j'avais
la ducati cayla donc tout est là tout
est situé exactement au même endroit
c'est très pratique ici c'est l'antre de
la vidéo mais c'est aussi l'entrée de la
mobilité comme ça on n'arrête pas le
progrès je vous remet un petit peu plus
comme ça voilà tout va bien c'est de
bien caler tout va bientôt le mieux
écrit scooter qui est vraiment gentille
et moi que j'adore j'utilise très très
très très souvent vous avez 50 euros de
remise au lieu de 399 vous la trouvez à
349 euros
donc ça c'est vraiment vraiment
intéressant alors voter quel modèle
prouve s'il voulait plus vite plus loin
mais celle là déjà
si vous n'avez pas des grandes côtes et
si vous voulez vous déplacer de façon
vraiment vraiment simple 349 euros c'est
vraiment vraiment canon comme tarif il
ya d'autres -qui vachement cool c'est le
projecteur laser me laser
vidéoprojecteur de xiaomi jeu
déjà montré plusieurs fois dans
différents événements vous avez une
offre qui vachement intéressante
vous avez 600 euros de remise sur la
bécane 600 euros au lieu de 1899 vous la
trouvez à 1299 si vous faire plaisir
vous avoir un tarif qui est hyper hyper
cannes et autres produits j'aime
beaucoup chez chaumet où ils ont fait
une offre hyper canon je vous en ai déjà
beaucoup parler c'est leur ennemi note 7
ans vous avez deux versions la version
32 gigas vous trouvez à 169 euros au
lieu de 199 euros il est hyper bien
positionné et la version 64 giga au lieu
de 249 de l'année à 189 euros
à ce tarif là un rémy note 7 ça a
toujours une valeur de référence ont
pensé faire un tour du côté le silo bon
marché où il ya plus deux autres milieux
dit que je trouve vraiment intéressante
à leur plus haut de gamme dans la gamme
raynaud de cette année c'est le x 10
jours qui est franchement hypra cool
vous avez 150 euros de remise écoute
emballement 799 euros vous trouvez à 649
euros dont vous dire que si voulez vous
équiper du côté de chez au pot soit le
plus haut de gamme en tout cas la gamme
raynaud c'est super qu'il faut prendre
alors il ya des remises sur le reno et
sur le reno et je pense qu'il vaut mieux
aller sur rennes 2 et éventuellement de
règne et deux aides mais qui par contre
non seulement pas de remise pour battre
à dire sur les productions très nouveau
et si vous voulez vraiment profiter d'un
tarif vraiment cool
lorenzo faut 10 où il est super bien à
649 euros c'est juste parfait
autre projet qui est vraiment cool chez
one plus one + 7 pro j'ai utilisé
pendant plusieurs mois
vraiment super smartphone l'écran 80 je
vous invite l avoir mon test il est
vraiment vraiment cool vous avez moins
140 euros croyez moi c'est vraiment
énorme du côté des one plus au lieu de
768 euros vous trouvez à 599 euros vous
avez un code fourni sur le site du wan
plus je mets le lien en bas dans les
script sion cliquer dessus pour aller
voir le code c 2019 bf lorsque vous
allez acheter et vous avez ce tarif là
en plus de vélos en plus ces deux pros
vous avez une coque de protection et
vous avez les écouteurs bonne plus
fournie avec tout ça c'est vachement
cool autres marques qui est vraiment
très très grosse et moi si apple alors
apple ils ont des offres qui sont
vraiment vraiment cool sur le macbook
air et macbook pro ya pas mal d'hommes
ça dépend de la config que vous voulez
vous avez jusqu'à -23 % sur le macbook
air et sur le macbook pro vous allez
pouvoir trouver des choses entre -13% à
-22% à l'exemple sur un macbook air ont
ils avoir un mais 99 euros vous trouvez
à 849 euros parmi eux plutôt pas mal
avec nous à 23%
ça me permet de toucher à des meilleurs
tarifs macbook air macbook pro autre
mystère intéressant c'est à l'iphone 10r
qui à défaut de 2000
18 mais qui reste quand même plutôt que
tuer le trouve bien qui est performant
qui marche bien les remises seront moins
impressionnante vous allez voir - 6 % de
remise
bon sur 40 euros de prix c'est toujours
ça honey 2 709 vous l'avez à 669 c'est
déjà ça de pris
et vous avez vos 30 euros sur la watch
series 3 plutôt cool d'être aussi plein
de choses vraiment intéressantes et
peut-être chez samsung sur les s10 ellis
plus et se 10e
le plus gros le plus grosses remises sur
le s 10 e au lieu de 750 9 vous trouvez
à 499 mois 260 euros ça c'est vraiment
ultra cool le s10 vous l'avez à moins
210 euros
wulf à 699 au lieu de 909 tombe bien
elles disent plus ou moins 210 799 au
lieu 2009 est vraiment cool
vous avez des oreillettes qui est
vraiment vraiment intéressant ça sur le
note 9 le note 9 reste toujours très
actuel le nôtre disque qui m'en a plus
de choses mais le note 9 par jour très
très bien l'écran est super avec le
stylet ou fait plein de choses c'est
vraiment cool
vous avez 410 euros de remise et ça
c'est pas mal quand même
849 euros au lieu de 1200 59 euros aux
produits qui sont vraiment intéressants
vous avez des remises sur la galaxie
watch et j'ai vraiment adoré et la
galaxie watch active je préfère la voie
de native de rock active mais elle est
pas mal pour a coûté un peu urbain ça
fonctionne vous avez de -26 s'avouant
vaincu % une fois de plus et tous les
liens la description et si vous voulez
une tablette qui coûte pas trop cher
chez samsung la galaxy tab ac qui s'est
déjà présenté on a moins 18 % de remise
à la saur à 229 au lieu de 279 euros
c'est une tablette je dirais plus
multimédia pour la maison c'est pas la
plus puissante on est loin d'une galaxy
tab à 6 mais elle fonctionne quand même
plutôt pas mal
donc ce un tarif qui relativement
intéressant homme sage très intéressante
à faire un tour du côté de chez huawei
huawei a des tweets sont vraiment cool
alors rassurez vous je vous le dis en
préambule tous les produits qui sont là
sur des produits la licence google vous
êtes tranquilles tout va bien se passer
vous aurez les mises à jour trottoir
tout se passe bien p smart 2019 vous
déjà présenté vous n'êtes pas 159 vendu
219 mois 67 coulpe et smartguide avec la
petite caméra pop up sans l'encoche 209
au lieu de 249 euros plutôt bien et 30
prompt et p30 vous avez moins de 100
euros
des deux côtés le p 30 pro ça vous le
soir à 649 au lieu de 1849 le paie 30 ça
vous le sort à 449 au lieu de 649 vous
avez aussi une remise à terme sur le
pétrole 'light au lieu de 3 129 vous la
veille à 249 euros
plutôt cool ayez un produit qui est bien
qui est pas de cette année qui est de 2
18 mai encore vachement actuel qui
marche très bien qu'ils aient accès
performance c'est le mec 20 pro ou là
vous avez moins 300 euros de remise au
lieu de 899 vous l'avez à 599 c'est une
machine qui reste toujours très
performante très actuel qui marche bien
et est de très bon rendu photo et qui à
ce tarif là est vraiment hyper
intéressant je vous ai noté aussi c'est
google le pixel 3a qui est le smartphone
milieu de gamme de google qui est
excellent en photo dans le milieu de
gamme
vous l'avez à 349 euros le 399 ça c'est
vraiment vraiment cool et c'est aussi le
pack friday simon par koné un rhino
shield vous avez du jeudi 28 novembre
j'aurai mes 40 ans jusqu'au mardi 3
décembre de 15 à 60 % sur tout le site
sur tous les produits rhinochill et en
plus avec le code monsieur drevet vous
avez 10% supplémentaires dont vous
pouvez y aller c'est le meilleur moment
de l'année pour offrir des produits
rhinochill quelle qu'elle soit que ce
soit de la protection d'écran que ce
soit de la coque solide que ce soit la
crainte vient tout ce que vous voulez
allez-y vous avez le lien en bas dans la
description est alors proche de celle
sur les deux trois autres trucs plutôt
dans l'audio notamment à la marche à la
tonne 2 est déjà présentée avec les
stalles mort de l'acteur 2 vous avez
moins 90 euros ça vous laissera 159 99
et 249 99 sont deux légendes marchal
sont hyper rock n roll ça marche pas ce
soir mais c'est très très cool je vous
trouve certes intéressant sur le casque
sony de w h mg 3 qui est le casque
référence au niveau de la réduction de
bruit ou de 349,99 vous l'avez à 299,99
senti ça c'est vraiment couleurs il ya
des remises aussi sur les casques billes
de trouver des choses pas mal aussi du
côté de google google nest est justement
gunless j'ai sélectionné neuf qui est
vachement bien il ya un pack exclusif
nac
le lien est en bas pack google l'est up
+ kit de démarrage philip sion c'est à
dire que vous avez votre google buzz qui
vous servira piloter votre maison plus
petits veaux éclairage pour avoir des
recettes de cuisine comme google est
voulu parler sûr que vous avez l'écran
plus c'est pas comme une tablette c'est
vraiment les âges différents
moi j'utilise je trouve vraiment bien et
vous avez carrément 100 euros de remise
au lieu de 299 99
vous l'avez à 199,99 donc si vous voulez
démarrer chez vous avec de l'éclairage
connectés et avec google à la maison
croyez-moi ça c'est vraiment un pack à
ne pas louper j'ai vu aussi des offres
du côté de la télé j'en ai trouvé que je
trouve vachement cool c'est la samsung
c'est la cuvette 55 pouces 4 cas vous
avez moins 600 euros de remise au lieu
de 1799 ça doit soir en 1199
il ya pas mal de télé il est pas mal de
vidéos proches je vous mets un lien
globale pour aller voir il reste
vraiment très intéressante
ça c'est vraiment hypra il fera hypra
coup je crois qu'on a fait à peu près le
tour de tout ce que j'ai sélectionné
tout de suite ça fait quand même pas mal
de choses
alors il ya beaucoup de choses il ya
aussi des consoles ya des caméras ya
vachement de choses je vous mets donc
des liens sur tous les produits
illicites et j'ai aussi des liens
globaux vous pouvez allez voir il ya des
actions vraiment hyper intéressante le
jour c'est à une soirée où il y avait
une étude de marché globale sur les
chiffres des smartphones des
progressions toussa toussa toussa toussa
il disait que noël est toujours une
phase d'achat qui marche très très bien
mais le black friday
ça lui emboîte le pas taton hypra
intéressante en fait vous êtes quasiment
un mois avant noël donc les gens
achètent au black friday
vous pouvez acheter beaucoup moins cher
quelques jours après vous allez acheter
plus cher pour le prix au même moment
voilà ça peut franchement avoir un
centre qui pour s'équiper c'est une date
qui va choix intéressant ça c'est
vraiment vraiment vraiment vraiment
marrant donc l'âge de sélectionner les
choses sur des produits dans lesquels je
vous parle mais aussi plein d'autres
univers moi c'est plutôt cool
et est ce que vous achetez vous au black
friday est ce que vous avez déjà acheté
des produits lors cette période est ce
que vous allez à renouveler et si oui
maintenant dites moi tout ça en bas en
commentaire je vous invite tous les
liens pouvez y aller vous cliquez sur ce
je vous embrasse
et je vous donne rendez vous dans
quelques jours pour vous parler de ma
sélection de noël
là je vous avais pas parlé de prix de
produits existantes là je vais vous dire
qu'est ce que je vous conseillerais moi
d'acheter à noël quels sont les produits
que je trouve intéressant d'ici quelques
jours pour ce je vous embrasse tous
rendez vous dès demain et où tu ne
parles était qu'il ya plein de choses à
dire il ya plein de trucs cool et dans
quelques jours je vous emmène à hawaï
c'est juste vous pour partir avec
qualcomm
il parle des oppresseurs de qualcomm qui
va arriver l'année prochaine le
snapdragon je vous dirai pas quel numéro
je dirais rien pour l'instant c'est
motus et bouche cousue n'est pas rare
d'en parler tess nous embargo je peux
pas vous le dire mais croyez moi ça va
dresser le portrait robot des
smartphones de 2020 de là où on va
pouvoir aller en terme de performances
des nouveautés des nouveaux usages des
trucs top j'ai déjà tout vu quasiment
croyez moi ça va être dingue et on en
reparle si quelques jours à hawaii sur
ce je vous embrasse
à demain ciao